start off a new little series it's going
to be cooking with Adam so I laid out
all the ingredients for like all the
ingredients all my fettuccine Bolognese
just passes over a horse's head
blood all over the counter top the
comments are just like looks so good
yeah love you Adam did you cut off so in
love with you yeah I'm so in love with
you just not a single one like are
people not noticing that they're like um
yum I'm gonna try this with my kids so
good okay the vegetables I added in my
ground beef and the ground pour I'm
using 80s for this 80 10 beef and then
10 horse meat dude hot and the horse
head is just like spinning in it and
he's just
mixing it around
first thing I like to do is just kind of
sous-vide the beef a little bit my
potion yeah it's a it's a pseudo suvi